the jello can experience and also it's
like try getting really high on a really
good weed and start thinking about those
fucking drones zooming around
Afghanistan and blast and missiles and
kids and it's like you'll really start
getting a clearer understanding of how
fucked up that is you know no matter
what even let's say even those drone
attacks we had to do them it's still
fucked up it still creates more of a
sensitivity towards people getting their
limbs blown off of their bodies in the
pursuit of some ridiculous war and that
kind of you know that's hitting the
military industrial complex it's hitting
the pharmaceutical companies because if
you start getting high you're gonna
start experiencing a better level of
happiness it's gonna make you start
dealing with your bullshit or maybe
it'll make you depress because you're
lazy but either way it won't allow you
to like sink into the kind of sedated
hypnosis that it seems like that works
really fucking well for Applebee's you
know it works really well for the
corporations for people to be in a
sedated hypnotic state where they can
really make sense of going down to a
shopping mall and buy and like eating at
a fucking I don't know chicken place
with their with their kids and then
going up and buying some shit at a shoe
store and then spending their day just
consuming shit they don't really need
and then going home and sitting back to
watch TV with more advertisements and
not thinking that's weird and falling
asleep in that kind of depressed slumber
that is really hard to do if you're high
if you're really high it's really hard
to watch normal TV and not be like this
is horrible look at these advertisements
are you kidding they think that they're
that's gonna work on me oh my god
forty-eight thousand dollars for a
fucking car you're gonna pay for that's
like over a year's wage for some people
you're gonna make sense of buying a
brand-new car payments of two hundred
and eighty-five dollars a month when you
for like four grand you can go buy a
fucking car get it fixed up through the
year and have like a shitload extra
money and not being debt that's what pot
makes you think if you're not you know
but if you're like
Runk and you're fucking scratching your
balls and watching the game and a
fucking the new lexus you'll start
thinking like well my credit score went
up this year I think I'm not being able
to take out a loan from the bank and get
a new Lexus even though you're fucking
broke and living in hell and it's gonna
just create this weight on your budget
that's gonna make you miserable dude I
don't mean to go on a long rant but did
I ever tell you the time a friend of
mine picked me up in his fucking
Mercedes and took me to his apartment
never tell you this no he had a brand
new Mercedes and I know this guy knew
what his job was pick me up in his and I
knew he couldn't afford a Mercedes picks
me up in his brand-new Mercedes and he's
like hey I gotta stop by my apartment
come inside for a second go into his
apartment it is the size of a fucking
closet it is the smallest apartment I've
ever seen in my life like barely could
be like he had to like kind of like
almost like walk sideways against the
wall to get around the bed to get to the
bathroom it's like a New York style just
shitbox meanwhile that guy's car
payments have got to be like 550 600 a
month I mean this is a nice fucking
Mercedes and in his mind he had like his
logic behind it was like yeah it's
better to have like a really nice car
than like a comfortable living situation
I talked about that he's like a deal one
last thing that guy is a tramp
demon his white goods he's a tramp demon
cuz tramp see that Mercedes and they're
like let's go back to your apartment cuz
they think he's rich and then they get
in this tiny little fuckin shitty closet
see they probably has some rap about
that they're making my new place they're
fixing up town I'm staying here for a
little while oh yeah yeah fuckin said
the look on those tramps face when they
walk in that door and realize that they
there's barely room to stand there's
like two feet of carpet between the door
and the bed there's a lot of people who
believe in those really small
sustainable houses you know that people
are making these like really really
little houses and you like move things
out for the kitchen and move things out
in the bed is like a live scene area and
you know and yeah like it's it's like a
whole trend on the Internet there's a
lot of
that's cool I don't think there's
anything wrong about living simply it's
just hilarious when people throw
themselves into hellish debt for a
symbol yeah and and and well it's not
just that honestly it's you you enjoy
the fuck out of a nice car shouldn't get
an Mercedes you can't believe you're
allowed to drive this thing you
everywhere you go people look at you
like you must be special looking at me
is getting into that Mercedes oh my god
for a lot of people that is a tangible
benefit of having a car like that they
like this now you could say it's shallow
all day but men driving one of those
things is beautiful it's a amazing piece
of engineering and as a gearhead you
know I'm sort of a minor league period
because I don't know exactly how all of
it works yeah but like Adam Carolla is
like a legit gear and he can like build
cars I just like buy them from people
who know how to build them and
appreciate the fuck out of them I think
they're interesting but the driving one
you drive like a really well engineered
piece of it's amazing no I man I I had
shit shit loads of money I would buy a
nice car and I wouldn't feel weird about
it cuz anything to like to dull the
fucking existential horror that comes
over me on the 101 and traffic that's
beautiful I understand when those
commercials you know they're they're not
just appealing to rich people they're
they're they're manipulating idiots
render somehow convincing them that
they're logically make sense to get in
debt to a bank for 50 grand it's not
just idiots it's people that are not
happy that's what they're offering you
happiness see most people throughout
their day they have a job that can
occasionally be interesting but they
would never fucking do for free and
whether they're good at or not they take
some sense of pride in their work they
get through their day but they're
fucking tired man and people are
unsatisfied they feel like they work so
fucking hard they put so much in and
what am I getting I'm just existing this
is what I'm doing I'm existing so what
do they do they get fucking shit they
buy a new bowling ball they get a new
heart they get a new Lexus and you know
what for them you know for some of those
you say it's sad but for some of those
guys that are stuck in that life no
matter what they do that might prevent
that might give them like a
a bit more happiness driving you know
yeah but that's plastic a nice new
Mustang on the label it's like eating
classic fucking fruit I mean really the
ideas get underneath that don't start
you're starting at the top start way
deep start down deep and then worry
about the fucking Mercedes yes
for you yes for you for you for a guy
who thinks but for someone who's just
locked into the life of a drone and
accepts it nice little red Mercedes look
at that yeah look at that look how Bob's
face he's so happy he gets into his red
Mercedes I don't know the girls hey
girls yeah I know five Mercedes but I
guess ladies you know like I get myself
in debt always have been I did the same
shit I don't buy Mercedes or go to that
crazy but my shit was always like I grew
up super poor and then now I have
credits so now I could buy things and
Duke like the most of my life was like
hand-me-down shit or you know like
shitty toys or you know just not like
you want you live in the neighborhood
with a bunch of kids to get anything
they wanted growing up I can oh I don't
know if you see these kids and you're
like wow you got Voltron how'd you get
Voltron that's just like $80 you know
and then now you're an adult you're kind
of over like you feel like I deserve
this cuz I didn't have that stuff
growing up I want what I want you know
like like these kids always had growing
give me any fun like objects of to
soothe them give me a big computer
monitor and fucking World of Warcraft
and some medicinal marijuana and that's
all I need and that cost thirteen
ninety-nine a month
[Applause]
[Music]